[Musique]
c'est un film de monstres gentils qui
tient la corde aux oscars cette année
avec 13 nominations la forme de lots de
guillermo del toro est le favori de
cette 90e édition un conte fantastique
une romance inédite entre une femme de
ménage muette est une créature amphi
bienne un grand film de cinéma qui a les
allures d'un classique hollywood lalande
qui était le film comme ça et pourtant
cette année on sent bien qu hollywood
envie de faire sa mue la farewell justin
est passée par là et a fait trembler
toute l'industrie
anat d'accueil moment mais est à l'ombre
un peu du mit tout mouvement sur
rassurent cette campagne car il s'agit
bien d'une campagne et ceux qui la
mènent tambour battant offre aux votants
de nouveaux visages plus féminin plus
métissée que juvénile renouvellement de
lady bird a commis bayonnais en passant
par gala août des petits films
indépendants sont star et sans gros
budget rivalisent avec les derniers
spielberg et christopher nolan
vont-ils tenir jusqu'à la ligne
d'arrivée l'académie des oscars est elle
en train de faire sa révolution
la campagne 2018 est elle celle du
nouveau siège
on a quitté les oscars sur un imbroglio
historique une cocasse erreur d'
enveloppe l'an dernier qui a conduit le
vénérable warren beatty a donné le
mauvais gagnant de l'oscar du meilleur
film
[Musique]
ce n'était pas la la land mais moonlight
comme un acte manqué annonciateur de la
fin d'une époque qui a un petit film
indépendant à la base et surtout c'est
par les internes mois sur une histoire
noire est homosexuel c'est quand même
c'était déjà assez rare à hollywood
donc je pense que ça on peut dire que
c'était déjà en attendant l'année
dernière
le tournant cette année porte le nom
d'un hashtag mitu impossible de ne pas
voir sur les nominations 2018 lettrage
du mouvement anti harcèlement n'est dans
le sillon de la sphère winch chine james
franco par exemple lauréat du golden
globe du meilleur acteur il ya à peine
trois semaines pour de grid disaster et
qui portait fièrement son king time's up
est absent des oscars tiens donc
il ya peut-être quand même l'impact de
toute cette histoire de plaintes
d'étudiantes dans sa classe des films
d'art l'acteur est dans la tourmente
depuis qu'il est accusé par cinq femmes
de harcèlement sexuel
scarlett johansson y a même fait
allusion lors de son discours à la
marche des femmes aux halles inverse
christopher plummer et nommé en meilleur
second rôle pour tout l'argent du monde
comme s'ils lui avaient suffi de
remplacer au pied levé le trait wanted
kevin ce pays si dans le film de ridley
scott pour décrocher sa domination
tu espères pas de doute cette année
l'académie aussi balance au port un peu
de la femme de ce pasteur prise de
pouvoir des femmes à hollywood
donc on a vu de sa mamie en noir pour le
blogging globe
j'imagine qu'elles vont faire pareil
pour les oscars et on peut dire que
c'est ce pourquoi un film comme on est
des bergues a toutes ses chances de
gagner
lady bird c'est le film qui affole les
critiques américains depuis qu'il a été
présenté en septembre au festival de
telluride là au moonlight avaient
d'ailleurs démarré sa carrière
un portrait d'adolescente qui entrent
dans l'âge adulte réalisé par la jeune
greta gehrig
elle est seulement la cinquième femme
nommée dans la catégorie meilleure
réalisation de toute l'histoire des
oscars car elle n'avait pas examiné aux
golden globes et ça avait fermé n'en
backlash mon avis mais en fait cette
histoire de nous tous on en parle sans
arrêt tira mais dans les faits il n'y a
pas encore une femme qui est nominé dans
la catégorie donc l'aller les oscars ont
rectifié le film a déjà récolté 40
millions de dollars au box office us
énorme score pour un film en des crêtes
à guerroyer rencontré plusieurs mois
avant sa nomination porte le visage
d'une génération de femmes qui veulent
prendre toute leur part à l'industrie du
cinéma
car ces chaînes il est une femme qui a
été en revanche complètement écartés de
la course aux oscars si la très
respectée catherine big lots jusqu'ici
seule femme à avoir été sacrée baisse
director il ya huit ans pour démineurs
moi je trouve ça scandaleux précédemment
comme un film dont comme deux trusts
détroit de kathryn bigelow y les
panneaux minutes ou alors que c'est un
film très politique très engagé en film
soit justement le problème des noirs aux
états unis en film fait par femme
mais il ya eu une polémique avant la
sortie du film aux états unis ce le fait
que kathryn bigalow avait pas le droit
de raconter cette histoire parce que
l'était pas noir est du coup bastos en
retrait le vif débat aux états unis sur
la légitimité d'une blanche à s'emparer
de la souffrance noir a en effet marqué
l'année cinéma là bas les oscars ont
tranché à haute catherine big lots mais
welcome gala août premier long métrage
de jordan pile un film d'horreur malin
sur fond de dénonciation du racisme
je pense que la nomination pour le gala
août dans la catégorie mais en films
notamment c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est historique avec un acteur noir
qu est nominé pour best acteurs êtes
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une volonté
comme ça de ramener du sang n'a fait de
choisir dessine emploi différent
le héros du film daniel kaluuya à 28 ans
il pourrait être le plus jeune lauréat
de l'oscar du meilleur acteur
mais il est concurrencé sur ce terrain
par timothée chalamet encore plus jeune
22 ans le plus jeune nommé dans cette
catégorie depuis 80 ans
dm tous genres donne ce qu'on a peur de
mieux qu'en meuse et donc il est assez
android des garçons avaient trait jamais
et c'est vrai qu'il est formidable le
film de luca guadagnino c'est comme yves
ailleurs name autre film indé salué par
la critique notamment pour la
performance de timothée chalamet
étonnant jeunes amoureux foudroyé par le
désir d'être nominée pour un oscar à 22
ans qu'on avait que ça c'est vraiment
des légendes c'est les gens non
seulement que j'admire mais que
littéralement j'ai étudié et dernier
cinq six ans alors d'être inclus avec
eux
c'est fou pour moi c'est tous des héros
trois poids lourds en effet lui font
face gary oldman grimé en turquie il
dans les heures sombres
daniel day-lewis dans phantom fred
korman avec trois oscars et denzel
washington dans la sphère romane j'ai
déjà nommé six fois chalamet va-t-il
créer la surprise
depuis quelques semaines on voit sa
bouille partout aux états unis fruit
d'une stratégie rondement menée par le
distributeur
je parie sur le fait que la wii en fait
tu me ses charmes et c'est peut-être
notre meilleur chien aux tendances car
donc on va le booster on va faire
beaucoup le comte annappes réduit depuis
des mois le réalisateur italien est
novice dans la course aux oscars
accompagne son comédien partout comme
pour soutenir un candidat aux élections
et ce genre et de tisanes job de répit
pour leur expertise you do have you
think you need to présente différents
sites web to many different group of
people mais celui qui était le masters
de world season campagne et ses
terrasses étaient armés one style alors
cessé le maître de la campagne aux
oscars
c'est l'autre fait majeur de cette année
pour la première fois le grand manitou
des oscars le champion des statuettes
toutes catégories ne fait pas partie de
la fête
il n'hésitait pas évidemment à dépenser
beaucoup d'argent mais ils étaient aussi
très persistant et ils établissent et
des liens très forts avec les
journalistes pour que les journalistes
parlent le mieux possible de défilement
question débrouiller pour que ses
talents à y ait le plus de visibilité
possible dans les médias d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il avait fait avec jean
dujardin
année historique en 2012 quand vie
artistes remporté cinq oscars dont
meilleur film meilleur réalisateur et
meilleur acteur pour jean dujardin qu'on
a vus faire des claquettes sur tous les
plateaux télé de demander une attachée
de presse de me fait rare espèce de sur
mesure parce que aller dans une émission
politique avec mon anglais de 6e ça
laisse aller vite plafonné avec ce vieux
complexe si vous l'achetez donc du coup
bah on sait qu'on passe une émission de
15 minutes 20 minutes c'est à peu près
ce qu'on va vous raconter ce qu'on va
vous poser comme question je me suis dit
quitte à le jouer ce truc là que ce qui
est impossible l'idée l'idée même
d'avoir l'oscar est un truc est
totalement futuriste
quand on n'y pense pas pour soi ce
possible donc on se dit beaucoup de
jouer et je me suis amusé j'ai fait
l'idiot
voilà donc ce qui attend nos petits
nouveaux s'ils veulent se faire une
place parmi les gros poissons
fin du suspense dimanche 4 mars on leur
souhaite bonne chance mais plutôt à
merde